Someone stole Alan Turing's grades and was
willing to give up their life to keep them.
Let's try to understand the surprising reason why.
I didn't plan to make any more videos
about Alan Turing But I came across a
story that just blew my mind. I was
actually on Wikipedia reading for a
different video when I saw a photo of Alan
Turing's PhD diploma and in the caption on
the Wikipedia article it said something like
this is the recently returned stolen document
from Alan Turing and I thought, What do
you mean, stolen? What's happened here?
Digging into the story more, I found that
a whole bunch of Alan Turing's documents,
including his PhD diploma, his school grades,
and some of his medals, have been recently,
or just last month, returned to
an Alan Turing archive at his old
school. These were repatriated documents
and had been stolen nearly 40 years ago.
I've got the court documents here
of what exactly went down. So I'm
going to go through the chronology of how this
happened and how they got the documents back,
and then show you what those stolen documents
were. These documents include his PhD diploma
and his school report cards, but also
some photos and medals of Turing's.
These seem like kind of unimportant documents.
But actually, to the woman who stole them,
she said that she would defend them with
her life. In fact, that these were her life,
and that these documents were so important to
her, that without them, she didn't think life
was worth living. It is a good outcome that
the documents are now back in the archive
that Turing's mother donated them to for other
people to read and look at and enjoy and study,
but for that one person who wanted them,
this is a bit of a heartbreaking story.
Alan Turing attended the Sherborne
School in England from 1926 to 1931,
before of course he would go on to do
really great things in mathematics,
including working on the Enigma machine, cracking
codes. But also becoming a leader in thinking
about the ideas of artificial intelligence
and mathematical underpinnings of computation.
After he tragically died in 1954, at just age 41,
Turing's mother donated a lot of his things
to the Sherborne School. They didn't have a
lot of security around their archives at the
time. And in 1984, a young woman in her early
20s came to visit the archives and asked to
look at anything they had about Alan Turing.
She asked a staff member from the school how
often people came to look at Turing's archives,
and they told her it didn't happen
very often. Turing wasn't really
that well known at the time. This is
before they made The Imitation Game,
a movie about him. But to this one woman,
she was really obsessed with Turing.
And after hearing that not many people
were coming to look at these materials,
she got the idea that maybe they would be
better off with her,and that they belonged
with her. When she left the school, unknown
to the librarian, she took a box of materials
with her. The school didn't have a very good
catalogue of exactly what it had, and didn't
even really notice anything was missing, until
they got a letter from the woman saying how sorry,
she was and she that she knew it was wrong,
that it had been hard for her to steal,
but that she would take good care of
the materials and one day return them.
She even returned some materials to the school,
but these don't seem to have been originals. They
included some replica medals that she seems
to have bought elsewhere And definitely not
all of the things that she took away with her,
the staff member who showed her around thought
she was a little odd and is quoted in the
court documents saying that he's familiar
with the eccentricities of Americans, but got
the impression that she had a crush on Turing.
Now, this woman was American and she took the
stolen documents back with her to America. The
Sherbourne School figured they probably weren't
going to see these documents again. They were
just hoping that maybe one day she would
return the rest of them. Now this woman's
name was Julia Schwinghamer. But in 1988,
a few years after the theft, she actually
changed her name to Julia Turing, representing
how deeply she was enamored with Alan Turing.
She saw him as kind of a father figure or
even a husband, despite the fact that he
died seven years before she was even born.
She never met him and wasn't related to him
at all. The best article that I found about
this story was one written by Chris Walker
in which he shows a lot of empathy for
Julia and why she was driven to want to
steal things from the archive rather
than just pinning her as a criminal.
It turns out that she had a really rough
upbringing. She was abandoned by her parents,
spent some time in foster care before
returning back to her biological mum,
but never feeling at home. She didn't know how
to read, but one day watched the movie Space
Odyssey and was really taken
by the character of Hal 9000,
the computer on board in the movie that
seems a bit like a sentient machine.
As a young girl this movie interested her
so much that she did something she'd never
done before and that was to go to a library.
There she asked a librarian if they had any
books about machines that could talk. The
librarian gave her a bunch of books about
computing but for a girl who didn't know how
to read these were a bit too hard to digest.
One of the books though contained
a photograph of Alan Turing and she
says that as soon as she opened it to this
page, she was overwhelmed with a sense of
familiarity looking at the photo. That
she checked out that book and just had
it open to that photo page for the entire
length of the loan and then renewed it.
Julia actually credits Alan Turing with
saving her life. That the inspiration
she got from him dictated a lot of what
she pursued and was able to do with her
life. She took up running because she heard
that Alan Turing had also been a good runner
and she actually went on to compete
at a really high level in athletics.
For someone who didn't have any adult role
models growing up, Julia really found a sense
of inspiration and motivation in Alan Turing,
despite having never met him. Her family were
aware of this obsession and teased her a bit about
it. And actually the next twist in the story comes
in 1988 when Julia was having a fight with her
sister Carol, as a way to get back at Julia,
what Carol did was to round up some of the
materials that she could find that Julia had
on Turing and took them to the police station.
She must have known that Julia had probably
stolen them. The police station received them
and sent them back to the Sherborne school. It
wasn't all of the materials though, Julia still
had some of them hidden in her house, but for her
she was heartbroken to know that the PhD diploma
was one of the materials that had been returned.
This next part is quite unbelievable, but
she wrote to Sherborne's school begging and
pleading them to let her keep the PhD diploma.
She writes, I am extremely worried about the
fate of Alan's PhD. It means everything to me. I
place my very life on it. She even writes that,
&quot;as I have written in my diary, I will
take my life if Alan's PhD cannot be returned.
I have protected it with my life in the past. I
have given up much for its safety and
will do so again if necessary.&quot;
And this is the unbelievable part. Over a
few letters, Julia is begging the Sherborne
school to let her have the diploma back. And
they agreed. Or I shouldn't say they agreed,
actually it was just that one staff
member who was receiving these letters.
The same guy who showed Julia around the archives
on the day that she stole them. I think that he
really did feel empathy for Julia and probably
thought the PhD was best placed in her hands.
It's not a decision he should have made on his
own, he definitely should have consulted the
other librarians or the school itself, but he
actually sent the PhD diploma back to Julia.
She happily kept possession of the diploma
and several other documents that she hadn't
told anyone about for a few more decades
until it all unraveled in 2018. That year,
Julia contacted the University of Colorado,
claiming to be a family member of Alan
Turing and offering to loan them some
of Alan Turing's documents for display.
She'd been inspired to do this because of the
growing interest in Alan Turing around the world
and she thought that some people might like to see
these documents That's true. Although they weren't
hers to be loaning out. The University of
Colorado were instantly a little suspicious
and they actually met with Julia in person and
looked at a bunch of the documents she had.
They researched some of those documents
and contacted the Sherbourne School,
who told them that a bunch of documents had been
stolen in the 1980s. The university passed this
information on to authorities, who issued a
search warrant for Julia's home. Where they
found heaps more materials, more than
she'd even been willing to lend out.
The police officers doing the search
actually asked Julia to help them look
for the items listed on the search warrant.
She agreed, and pretended to look for stuff,
but appeared distracted. They noticed that
she kept looking towards the bathroom,
so they asked her to step outside and
wait for them to continue the search,
and then they went back into the
bathroom and did a second look there.
They found that a part of the
wall was actually removable,
and behind that it led to a gap under the
stairs, and there they found an old leather
briefcase. In that briefcase was a bunch more
materials belonging to Sherborne School. There
was a handwritten note from Turing's
mother, and even a handwritten note from
the king apologizing for not being able to award
Turing's medal in person because he'd been sick.
The estimated value of all the
stolen materials is around $38,000,
and as of last month, these were
returned to the Sherborne School,
who have kindly made many of them publicly
available on the school website. Years ago,
I made a video about Alan Turing's grades, but
those were just the ones available at the time.
It's finally time for a part two of that video,
looking at the rest of Alan Turing's grades,
now that we have a complete picture
of what his time was like at school.
This first report card is from 1924,
when Alan was around 12. His Latin
teacher said that his work was spoiled
by bad writing and lack of neatness.
This is a common theme throughout his report
cards. In French, he was top of the class,
probably because his parents had
been living in France. And in math,
he wasn't top of the class. In fact, he
was fourth out of eight students. It says
in excellent terms work. He has absorbed
90 percent of what he has been taught.
And coming only fourth out of eight
in the class kind of means nothing,
especially at an early age. To go on
and achieve great things in mathematics,
you don't have to have always been top
of the class. Overall, very good work,
but his writing has got as bad as ever again. Now
in 1926, when he's 14, Turing's history teacher
says that he comes out with surprising information
at times, but has on the whole worked very well.
His Latin teacher describes him as
delightfully ingenious and unspoiled.
He shows distinct promise. In mathematics,
this time he ranks fifth. With the teacher
saying that he has done very well
and his steady application is much
to be commended. His headmaster describes him
as original, a very interesting character.
Honestly, that's how many people
would describe Alan Turing today,
looking back at his achievements. The
next term, that same headmaster said,
he appears self contained and is apt to be
solitary. This is not due to moroseness,
but simply, I think, to a shy disposition.
In math, again, he is fifth. Very good work.
His work is thoughtful and promising. The remark
from the history teacher stings a little bit. It
says, tries hard, but has very little knowledge.
This next one, from when he was aged 15, is kind
of funny. His English teacher absolutely rips
into him. Seems like perhaps they didn't get along
that well. The teacher says I can forgive his
writing though it is the worst I have ever seen.
I am squinting to make out the next sentence.
I think it says I try now to tolerate his
handwriting, inexactitude, and something dirty
work, inconsistency, something, something,
something. He's being ripped into about how
bad his handwriting is, but the ironic thing
is that I can't read this comment from the
teacher because I can't read this handwriting.
I can make out this part, the teacher says, but
I cannot forgive the stupidity of his attitude
towards name discussion on the New Testament.
With a note, he has been caught doing algebra
during divinity lesson. Maybe this is when
Turing got truly interested in mathematics.
It's funny to me to see a report growling a
student for doing algebra during another class.
But maybe to Turing the algebra was truly
more enjoyable than the divinity lesson.
Seems like he also ranked last in that class
or close to it. This same year in mathematics
he has risen to first in the class. The teacher
said he's a very interesting boy to take. He is
full of ideas. In science they say
he is of course a very promising
boy but is frequently untidy both
in written and experimental work.
This must be cured. Of course, people
thinking they could cure Alan Turing
of supposed ailments caused him much pain
throughout his life when he was chemically
castrated for being gay. This is different,
but shows a bit of the culture at the time
that anything different was something
to be cured, and Turing might have been
used to hearing that people considered
things he did and who he was to be wrong.
By the time he's 18, it seems that Turing
was able to improve his handwriting or at
least satisfy the teachers. One teacher
says that he continues to be a genius
intellectual. And the same English
teacher that ripped into him a few
years ago seems to be in a better mood,
saying that he has intelligent work.
This is his final school report card upon leaving
Sherbourne School, and by now he has been awarded
a scholarship to attend King's College in
Cambridge. The headmaster writes that he
is a gifted and distinguished boy, whose future
career we shall watch with much interest. I have
found him pleasant and friendly, and I believe he
has justified his appointment as a school prefect.
On the screen now you'll see a link to my
previous video going through more of his
grades. Thank you for watching this video,
and thank you to my Patreon supporters for
making it possible. A special shout out to
today's Patreon cat of the day, Ma-Chan.